no God's funny now the God that I don't
even believe in anymore it's funny cuz
and now you can you're gonna die now in
a painful way and that's gonna be the
end I think that when push comes to
shove there is as much reason to despair
and be cynical as there is to be hopeful
and and believe in the possibilities of
life really triumphing and the cuz it's
really equal on both sides the real
heroism is to go up in the morning and
say okay it's equal on both sides I'm
going to take the risk I'm going to risk
hope I'm going to risk love but that
seems to have been always expressed
increasingly new technologies increasing
a new use of our minds to to fashion
objects that allow us to use that ever
evolving consciousness now sometimes
that technology is ahead of our
consciousness so you can you know you
can build a technology that actually
kills you and that's one of the one of
the real features of this moment is
we've been through three or four major
technological and send psycho-spiritual
moments of transition so whether it's
from hunter or grin from hunter gatherer
to agrarian to industrial now too we can
call this technological or informational
or post-industrial and that goes with a
spiritual cycle psycho evolution and if
those two things aren't together a lot
of people get killed on the mix and now
right now one of the issues if we are on
that transition we have a technology
that actually captures the deepest
spiritual insights the deepest spiritual
insight is that we are all
interdependent and connected that's the
fundamental spiritual inside of every
single tradition we are and because we
are interconnected and because we're
interdependent we have to treat each
other in a certain way because when I
treat you I'm actually just treating
myself in a different form now that
takes a lot of awareness to get to to
feel that that's why you have spiritual
traditions doing there
teaching on the wisdom side and a lot of
practices to try to make that happen for
the first time in human history we
actually have a technology that matches
that spiritual insight that's what it
means to have a global community that's
what it means to be able to have a of a
global web you know people really are
interconnected and I think that's
mind-blowing because for a lot of people
for sure it's mind-blowing because it's
one thing to kind of you know you know
kind of talk about it in some kind of
highfalutin spirituali we're all
interconnected world interdependent and
a a butterfly and you know in Alaska and
you know Mexico waves that's very nice
but here you go online and you see the
technology and you are my daughter has
pen pals all over the world she went to
hungry for a summer and and she has pen
pals in pen pal she has relationships on
I aming people in India she's I having
people in Russia she's I aming people in
Hungary you know I mean my parents my
father came here in 1938 from Poland it
was the longest kid he had never
traveled more than seven miles in his
life and he was traveling across the
ocean and now you know my daughter can
go puffs and talk to someone Indian and
see what her house looks like and so
that technology which in sent in a sense
concrete eyeses and realizes the deepest
spiritual insights now it realizes it in
the material world what the spiritual
spiritual insight is it was more than
just the material world that there's an
emotional intellectual and spiritual and
ethical world of meaning pastenaga
you